[Music]  i  love my life i love you so much gary  i'll never forget the day we met hello  little snail what's your name  gary huh do you want to be friends  me too gary  i'm home gary gare  [Music]  [Music]  get ready for the ultimate rescue  mission  in the all-new spongebob movie this is  gonna be like  one of those bloody movies  with aquafina you're fired danny trejo  snoop dogg no surprise bob tiffany  seriously folks i'm floundering  and keanu reeves call me sage i'm made  out of sage and i am a sage  so it works out pretty well see how the  gang all met  [Music]  little dude and experience spongebob's  biggest adventure ever ew  sorry steve's fam patrick what are you  doing  free food  the all-new spongebob movie sponge on  the run premiering march 4th rented from  these digital stores  also streaming on paramount plus  [Music]  you